michael phelps just gave us all the  fields we got him bring tears smiles huh  the 31 year old swimmer was fresh off  winning his 20th olympic gold medal in  Rio on Tuesday night when he pulled at  everyone's heart strings by tearing up  on the podium after receiving his medal  but then the most decorated Olympian of  all time stole our hearts as he headed  over to the stands to celebrate with his  mother fiance Nicole and three-month-old  son Michael hugged and kissed both his  mom and Nicole and grabbed his little  man boomer for an adorable embrace in a  touching moment after a preliminary race  on Wednesday  Phelps opened up about what it was like  having his son there to watch his daddy  win I wanted to be with him more so  being able to share that one moment that  I had with him definitely something very  special